- [Instructor] in this
video I want to look
at popular uprisings in
late medieval Europe.
So we're talking about between roughly
the 14th and the 16th centuries.
And these are sometimes
known as peasants' revolts,
and we'll talk a little
later about whether or not
that's a really an appropriate term given
who actually participated in the events.
But for now, we'll refer to
them as popular uprisings,
which means that they involved
a lot of common people.
As we look at these events,
we want to keep two questions in mind,
sort of big-picture questions.
The first is why did
people choose to revolt
against their government?
And especially after about the 1320s,
we see a huge number of
these popular uprisings
in a way that just didn't
happen prior to this point.
So why did this happen?
Why did people rebel?
And secondly, we want to think about
were these uprisings successful?
And if so, what does success look like
in these circumstances?
So I want to start with
a specific example,
and that example is the
Peasants' Revolt in England.
This occurs in the year 1381.
So we have a picture here,
and this is a picture from The
Chronicles of Jean Froissart,
and he is writing his
chronicles of what's going on
at the same time that
these events are occurring.
So it's a contemporary account.
The picture is actually from later.
It's added back into the Chronicles later,
so the picture is not entirely
accurate of the period,
but it does give us a sense
of what it might look like
for the king to be confronted
by thousands of angry subjects.
But to go into what they were doing there,
I want to start with a quote
and this again comes from The
Chronicles of Jean Froissart
that I mentioned and this is a quote
that he attributes to John Ball.
John Ball is an English priest
who is preaching at this time
and is considered maybe
one of the instigators,
one of the people who helps
start this revolt in 1381
and part of that is he's spreading ideas
that challenge the existing
authority structure.
And he goes on and says,
"Ah ye good people,
"the matters goeth not
well to pass in England,"
and that's kind of an
old-time way of saying
things aren't going well in England.
And then he goes on and says,
"Nor shall not do till
everything be common
"and that there be no
villains nor gentlemen,
"but that we may all be united together
"and that the lords be no
greater masters than we be it."
So what he's saying there is we have
this structure of society in England
where there are the gentlemen,
the people who are part of the nobility,
and they have this access
to political power and economic power.
And then we have all these other people
who have to basically do work
to support this nobility.
And he says we should really all be equal
and things aren't going to be
well in England until we are.
So that's a pretty radical message
especially for a medieval
European country.
And he goes on and askes this question
and says, "What have we, what
have we the common people
deserved or why should we
be kept thus in servage,
servitude or bondage,
"We be all come from one father
"and one mother, Adam and Eve,
"whereby can they say or show that
"they'd be greater lords than we be."
And what he's doing
there is making an appeal
to the Old Testament of the Bible
and saying that everybody is descended
from the same pair of people.
So we all really are equal in that sense,
so why is it that the nobility have access
to this greater power and wealth.
I should point out that
this idea of challenging
the social hierarchy is not the
only thing that's motivating
rebels in the Peasants'
revolt in England here.
There are a lot of other factors,
and we'll talk about those a little later.
So when we talk about
medieval European society,
before this point we have a structure
that has three estates, three levels
or classes you could think of this as.
And we have the clergy
which are priests or friars,
and basically anyone
involved with the church
and that is the group of those who pray.
You have the nobility and this
is going to be your Knights,
your people who are in control
of large tracts of land
that they hold in service to
the king and to the kingdom
and those are the people who fight.
And then at the bottom you
have the people who work,
which is including most of the population.
Remember this is a low
technology agricultural society.
We're talking about probably
90% plus of the population
is involved in agricultural
production in some way.
So this is the largest chunk of society
and they refer to that as the peasantry.
So to recap that your your model is
you have those who pray, those who fight,
and those who work.
The society needs all of these
roles to function properly,
so all of them are important.
So we want to think about how do we go
from this situation where we have
this relatively stable social order
where the different estates are seen
as more or less equally
important members of society
to what we see in England in 1381
where the people rise up and challenge
the authority of the king.
So there are three broad areas of analysis
that we can use to better understand why
we see these popular revolts breaking out
throughout the 14th century.
The first one of those is demographics
or the study of population.
And we have two major
events that significantly
impact Europe's population here.
The first one is the Great Famine
which occurs between 1315 and 1317,
and that refers to a sequence
of poor agricultural harvests
due to poor weather for
agriculture at this time.
The other event that has a major impact
on Europe's population is
the outbreak of the plague,
the Black Death it's called,
which occurs between 1347 and 1349 here.
And this ends up killing between a third
and a half of Europe's population.
So what you see is a big increase
in how much it costs to hire workers.
And you actually see
in England for example,
in 1349 and 1351,
you see a couple of laws passed
that try to keep workers
wages at pre-plague levels.
So it's a response to the fact that
there are now fewer workers and that makes
workers more expensive.
On top of that, you also
have the Hundred Years' War
going on between England and France.
It starts in 1337 and drags on actually
for more than a hundred years,
but that's the name they've given it.
But that's expensive.
That costs both governments a lot of money
to keep fighting and
maintaining militaries
and so at the same time that you have
these economic problems and struggles,
you also have government's
raising taxes on people
to try and pay for this conflict.
And the last thing that helps explain
some of these uprisings
these popular uprisings,
we saw a little bit already
in John Ball's quote,
but we have religious and cultural issues
going on as well.
The mendicant orders,
the Franciscans and the
Dominicans who are friars,
who go around and preach to common people
and preach the value of
poverty and simple living.
So when you have nobility who are living
very lavish and extravagant lifestyles,
you have some some pushback
against that as being
perhaps against the popular
religious attitudes of the time.
I mentioned at the beginning
that we would talk a little bit
about whether or not a peasant revolt
was the proper name for these events.
And we have in 1358 an event,
known as the Jacquerie,
which is a popular uprising
in the north of France
spurred because of issues relating
to the Hundred Years' War, actually.
And the Jacquerie gets
its name from the fact
that common people kind
of generically called,
Jacques Bonhomme,
like a regular guy was a Jacques Bonhomme,
and then that just translates to something
roughly like, Jack Goodfellow.
So what you see is the elites,
the clergy, the nobility
are applying this notion
of being a peasant,
of being a commoner,
in kind of a derogatory or insulting way
to anyone who's not part of
the nobility or the clergy.
And remember that when we
said what a peasant really is
it refers to a rural agricultural worker.
These revolts, these uprisings,
included a lot more than just
rural agricultural workers.
What they're trying to do
is to dismiss the uprising
as just bad behavior from people
who don't know their place in society.
But in reality, it's much
more complex than that.
So hopefully this starts
to give us a sense
of why did people revolt
against the government at this time.
We had these demographic changes that lead
to these economic changes,
and that leads in some ways to changes
in how people view their roles in society.
To think about whether or
not these were successful,
we want to think about more
than just military success,
because the fact is most
of these popular uprisings
lost militarily-speaking.
The government had more than enough
manpower and money to put
down these popular uprisings.
So when we think about whether or not
these popular uprisings were successful,
we want to think about did
they lead to any major changes
in the social or political structures.
Even if they didn't
win military victories.
And in most cases,
we do see some of those
changes start to take shape.